what do you kelly ripa and Shakira have
in common they can both dance jump Etta
we try we inspire each other let's give
you some background
Shakira left us stunned after her Super
Bowl halftime show performance where she
showed off some signature trumpet the
moves it's a genre of dance originating
in her home country Colombia shakira
launched the official Champa challenge
on Instagram and our girl Kelly
responded in a major way
yep that's Kelly over there on the right
dancing with her trainer Anna Kaiser and
another pal the trio really went full
out getting in a solid cardio sesh while
flexing some serious chump at the moves
the 49 year old TV host wrote in the
caption three mothers seven children 36
pack I would say a hashtag on the dance
floor when it comes to the Colombian
superstar Kelly has made it pretty clear
she stands just days before the Super
Bowl kelly reposted this video her
trainer shared on instagram trying to
land a spot in Shakira set here at Super
Bowl admission the only person kelly may
adore more than shakira is her husband
of 23 years Mark Consuelos he was with
the couple in 1996 just months after
they tied the knot
I always head over heels before we even
actually work together on understand
over two decades later they're still
pretty darn smitten we like each other
yeah we like each other sometimes we
like each other more than we like each
other but I like you already Darius
today's a good day
I think today's a good day
[Music]